tens of thousands of people are being
moved to emergency shelters in the
southern and central parts of the
country officials say around a hundred
thousand villages are in the projected
path of the typhoon jamila allendogan is
in manila with more on the rescue
efforts
it is the most powerful storm to hit the
philippines this year a hundred thousand
people have already fled their homes
typhoon rai made landfall on thursday
and continues to batter the regions of
visayas and mindanao
coast guards are rushing to evacuate
hundreds of residents after incessant
rains flooded their communities
young and old many are forced to leave
their homes with only the clothes on
their backs
residents carry what they can with many
hoping any damage will be limited and
they'll be able to return home soon
the philippines is no stranger to
natural disasters it is constantly
battered by storms and volcanic
eruptions
typhoon hayan in 2013 holds the record
as the strongest anywhere in the world
it killed at least seven thousand people
and displaced millions more since then
the government has institutionalized
emergency and disaster response but even
in a country long affected by around 20
storms each year typhoon rai comes at
the most precarious time
those evacuated can stay in temporary
shelters for too long because of kobit
19 restrictions while those in coastal
and farmland communities say they are
already bearing the brunt of an economic
recession and fear that the typhoon
could obliterate whatever livelihood
they have left
the philippine government has
pre-positioned aid and military as first
responders across the country but the
typhoon is expected to impact so many
provinces it has warned local officials
to prepare for the worst
jamal alindogan al jazeera manila